well thank you very much for inviting me
uh again for the year to
give a talk on this uh line of work
and i promise you for those of you who
were at here uh the last workshop or the
one before it's gonna be a totally
different talk so i hope it's not going
to bore you
so this work comes from
perhaps more directly
complexity theory than many of the talks
you have heard today
and i'd like to
show you that there are some
very nifty uh
connections with the very classical
mathematics that we can use to prove
classification theorems in complexity
theory that's what this is
and um
i would only talk about a few aspects of
the connections and i hope i can
interest many of your experts here on
representation theories and tensor and
transformations that i think there's a
lot to be done and i would really love
to hear
new ideas that you can use
so um
the um
the framework that i like to talk okay
so let me first say who which which
seagull theorem sql has many theorems
so the theorem that i would be using
more in spirit really because we want a
very effective version of it
is to say that if you have an algebraic
curve of genus at least one
then with integer coefficients
then there are only finitely many
integer solutions
okay
and in fact there's a bigger cousin
bigger hammer of it about
rational solutions
we don't need this actually
but even for integer solutions even for
very simple equations
uh
many of you probably know that the
behavior could be very wild i mean you
know if you just try a few numbers it
doesn't work it doesn't mean that there
are no solutions and in fact you know
the smallest solution of this is like
that okay and if you try a little more
you find no more then you don't think
there are no more in fact there are
infinitely many solutions
okay they are you know there
okay so
questions of the sort tend to be rather
uh difficult i think in general and it's
very deep mathematical questions but it
turns out and to my delight that
these actually
are really the key to some of the proofs
that we have to make in complexity
theory in this particular case to show
that certain uh polynomial time
reductions in fact work
okay so
the proof of hardness hinges on the fact
that there are no more integer solutions
okay now what is edge coloring i uh have
uh three type three phrases in my title
one is a zego serum this is edge
coloring well this is a definition by
picture everybody can see what that
means right you color the edges of a
graph
with various different
colors
subject to certain constraints at every
vertex so at the vertex you want in this
particular case that they're all of this
different color that's a proper edge
coloring okay you don't have two green
edges attached to the same vertex that's
edge coloring
so what's known about
a proper edge coloring using
the mini the maximum degree plus one
colors is always possible you know the
maximum degree of course is obviously a
lower bound you must use at least as
many some graphs can be colored with
this many colors and some can't
and the
the universal upper bound that always
works is plus one
kate in 1880 proved that for bridgeless
three regular planar graphs
this statement that
a 3-h coloring always exists which is
true
is equivalent to the four-color
theorem
it was a theorem at the time
because it was a conjecture before and
it was proved by kampa
and for a period of about 10 years it
was a theorem
until it was
found that there was an error
and that became a five color theorem
but a statement that tape theorem that
their equivalent is still valid and this
became of course another theorem
afterwards uh 1970s
ridgeless is important because if you
have a bridge
then uh three coloring doesn't exist
that's easy to prove
so therefore in particular for this np
question if you will
give me a planar graph is it h3
colorable has a trivial np certificate
just to check for bridge
but to prove that it's correct this this
certificate is correct is essentially
the full coverage theorem
okay so there are you know some
certificates of np correctness uh is not
obvious to prove that it's actually
correct certificate
in general uh for non-planar
this was shown in the 80s that this was
np-complete so we're talking about
whether or not there exists a coloring
okay
the
corresponding problem for every np
problem basically you can talk about the
counting version of it so if there
exists one or how many are there yes of
course if you know how many then you can
know if there exists but in general not
the other way around so this other class
called the sharpie which sort of talked
about all the counting versions of np
uh can be applied to here for edge
coloring and this problem is open for um
all these uh some i don't know 30 years
and most of the np complete reductions
are what's called a passimonious in the
sense that the reductions going from say
satisfiability to a np complete problem
preserves the number of solutions so if
you knew the solution of the target
problem you could turn out turn around
and solve this counting problem of the
original problem and this way will give
you a sharpie reduction but in this case
dominic welsh actually showed that this
reduction
for edge coloring cannot be made
possible so that's perhaps why this
problem is still open for counting okay
so the problem we are going to be
talking about the edge coloring is the
counting complexity of edge coloring so
it seems to have nothing to do with uh
zigel's theorem right i mean what does
zego theorem have to do with this
okay so so let me before more about what
the problem we're talking about you're
given uh a graph
input
and you want to know the number of valid
edge coloring using copper colors
okay
so if there are none then it's not even
copper colorable but they generally want
to know how many and that's the
computational problem
and for computational complexity the
problem is formulated this way the input
is measured in the size of the graph
and then output is this quantity and
then you want to know
what's the computational complexity of
doing this computation
okay is it exponential time is it empty
complete is it sharpie complete is it a
polynomial time computer
okay so is it clear what the
setting is
um so the theorem that we would be
talking about is that uh for every uh
parameter kappa number colors are
regularity of the graph
that uh
the problem is shall be complete so this
this was the open problem from 1980
sorry so is it known to be in sharp key
yeah because uh you know an np type
turing machine can just guess a
particular assignment of the edge colors
among one of the cake colors on every
edge and verify at every vertex it is
and the number of accepting paths is
exactly the number valid h so these are
obviously sharp p problems just because
the way you phrase the zero less
that's the only reason i asked yeah it
is it is okay
good
so uh the proof uh
is actually separate into two parts with
the copper the parameter equal to r or
bigger
and uh these are proved in the framework
of complexity dichotomy theorems and
that's my third
phrase in the title so i'm going now
move into this uh
description of this framework of
dichotomy theorems and counting props
these problems come in at least in three
varieties of graph homomorphism
constraint satisfaction problems and
holland problems
okay
in each framework there has been a
remarkable progress in the
classification program
of the complexity so the the typical
problem there is almost like a meta
problem where you want to say for every
type of constraints that describes the
problem the problem is either going to
be in polynomial time solvable or hard
for the respective complexity class such
as np or sharp
and so for example for the
for the edge coloring you will be
talking about its local constraint
function which says that i'm sitting at
a vertex i'm looking at the edges coming
in and my decision is they must be all
distinct
okay so that's the edge coloring
constraint function and then you say
that if there isn't a look is there an
assignment to every edge so that
everywhere the constraint is satisfied
then this is a satisfaction it's a
satisfaction problem right
okay
good so uh there has been remarkable
progress i think in all three constrain
frameworks
but this particular problem of edge
coloring is naturally phrased in the
harlem framework so i will turn to this
first and i want to keep the
terminologies to the minimum and i want
to explain by uh examples but some
minimal amount of terminology is
necessary so we are so bear with me we
have a graph okay g
and then you have a set of constraint
functions like for example all distinct
every local cons assignment must be of
assigning a different edge column
and then this pi assigns a function to
every vertex so this is a labeling of
constraints at every vertex
and then you look at say over the
boolean domain for now you want to
assign every edge to be either in or out
and then for the particular assignment
of the edges of 0 1 you look at every
vertex where there is an associated
constraint function and you evaluate
this constraint function locally with
respect to the particular assignment on
the edges that are incident to this
vertex
and then you multiply them and you sum
them it's a sum of product type
computation
okay it has a lot of rich history of uh
trying to express things of the sort
like in statistical physics where you
have partition functions you sum over
spins of of particles and you multiply
at every edge of the interaction force
in statistics usually this product is
expressed as e to the some lambda of the
sum of the local things and these are
called hamiltonian on the exponent and
you sum of the
e to the sum okay which is really sum of
products okay
i'm going to try to think of a
constraint function as simply a truth
table of
of length 2 to the n so think of this as
a vector or a tensor
but
thinking in terms of tensor there's a
way to express it as sort of tensor
products and sums and particularly i
think would be interesting to the people
in this workshop you have this
expression for for example the function
where you have two to the n entries
where this thing will when you expand
out it becomes one zero zero zero zero
zero zero of two to the n long plus the
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero one
of two to the n long and when you add
them up it has only two
ones two non-zeros at the very beginning
and very end and they are indexed by
the
index of zero zero zero zero zero zero
and one one one one one and everywhere
else is zero so if you are just a
computer scientist you know this is a
truth table
and it represents a particularly simple
function the function is the equality
function the all n bits must be equal
okay so
thinking this in totality as an
amalgamation of two things together as a
single entity it's just a truth table of
a particular function
but you split it into this form then you
can start to talk about what's called
holographic transformations so you act
this other matrix to the tensor nth
power to this thing
well one of the beautiful thing about
matrix product with respect to tensor
product is that you can distribute
right so you distribute the h term and
then it becomes h times this to the nth
tensor power
right doesn't make sense so i have
h
times 1 0 which is just the first column
right and then if i do this to the nth
power
this just becomes all one things
and if he did this of 0 1
then this becomes 1 minus 1
to the n and this becomes a 1 minus 1 1
minus 1.
okay
depends on how you label the things if
you label this thing lexicographically
would be one minus one minus one plus
one and so on so forth okay so basically
what you have now is two vectors
expressed this way and then now you
reassemble them and there will be
cancellations happening
and this turns out if you look at it
it's the parity function
so what we have just done is some sort
of a magical transformation by the other
matrix this one one minus one
technically you multiply by one over
square root of 2 to be orthogonal
that would transform the equality
function to parity function
okay and so if you think in terms of
this way then there's a natural group
action you can think of some sort of
group
of which h might be a member and you
would act on the set of functions
constraint functions and then it will
produce a transformation from one
function to another and they form some
sort of orbits and you can try to
understand the properties of these
orbits
and this is sort of in in one way of
thinking what holographic transformation
is about okay you split up the actual
you you know unitary thing which is just
a zero one things and you split
arbitrarily in an algebraic way and they
try to transform separately and
recombine and cancellation happen and
somehow
you can sort of change the character of
one function to another
and since this workshop is you know with
so many great experts in representation
theory let me just mention one simple
slide of a
a really a a tip of iceberg of what i
think there's a lot of ways that you can
use your theory in this in this domain
this particular thing has no bearing on
particular result i'm about to say but
it should suggest
ways that you can apply
right if you take the sl2
it's the complexification of the su-2
okay
and then uh since the su-2 is the lead
group the really group of su-2 they're
simply connected
compact there's a one-to-one
correspondence between the
representations of this
and the representation of these without
the h and the representation of the suit
and in fact this is how
you you start your theory of semi simple
the algebra representation that this sl2
thing is really sort of the the most
basic structure you try to find in every
single the algebra and you have this
little h and x and y and so on you act
them and you're trying to find that
there are highest weight vectors and
trying to classify them right but what
i'm trying to say to you now is that if
you take about a symmetric constraint
function so this is just a shorthand
notation to say that it's a function of
2 to the n long but it is symmetric it
says that if the hemming weight of the
input of 0 0 0 0 is hemingway 0 and the
value is f sub 0 if the hemingweight is
one you know one zero zero zero or zero
one zero zero whatever input coming in
is is a hemingway one thing then you
have a value f1
these are called the symmetric
signatures of symmetric constraint
functions and you can act by an element
of su 2 to transform this and this is
like basically what i did for the
automatic transformation on the identity
function
and this is a group action obviously
okay
now you can also do something else you
can take a bivariate polynomial
okay homogeneous degree n with n plus
one term
and then you act
on this polynomial in this following way
where you define starting from a p to
get a new polynomial q where the
definition of q x y is just the p of x y
times u so you think of x y as a row
vector multiplied by the two by two u it
gives you new
uh two terms thing each of which is a
linear form in x and y and then you
re-express them as a homogeneous
polynomial which have these coefficients
so you change these coefficients to
those coefficients this is in fact the
canonical way you get the unique
irreducible representation of sl2 in
dimension n plus one
and the simple theorem you can just
check yourself that they are exactly the
same
so this really should suggest there are
some deeper connections
of of of signature and holographic
transformations and your representations
here in particular we have very little
understanding when the domain size which
is where the variable takes value so
either true or false for example that's
the boolean domain case
when that size of the domain size is
more than two when it's not boolean so
for example edge coloring i want to
color red and green and blue and on
these three different input possible
values per each variable and the
constraint function may say something
okay and so these are the places where i
think you know a deeper understanding of
the
constraint functions on higher domains
can benefit from representation
any questions uh well
sort of more a comment i think
this this vector space of two to the n
has a has a sort of another secret group
acting on it
the spin yes yes and
somehow
that has to do with the match gates yeah
that's really the match case
um so so somehow it really should be a
story about these two different groups
not just about the oh yeah you can you
can think of any in fact the orthogonal
group is very interesting as an action
yeah and different groups definitely
yeah the spin seems to be like really
important for the picture
okay i'd like to talk to you more about
uh
that particular one um
yeah all i'm saying is that you know um
there are ways that you can think of
these hot transformations in that
language yeah no i completely agree but
what i'm saying is i would suggest
thinking of it in terms of
a space that has two groups acting on it
one is this change these kind of as the
cousin of su2
the admissible changes of basis or
whatever you want to call it and then
the other one is kind of coming from the
problem
that that you want to solve and yeah
yeah the interplay between the two that
that sort of is it's really beautiful i
i completely agree with you but but jim
i also
would like to suggest that um
there's actually more than just the
match gates that's being played here and
this edge coloring in fact uh
doesn't quite directly having it
but i suspect whenever you get this kind
of you know things that just
fall into p that there's this other
group kind of hiding in the background
that's i i completely agree yeah
absolutely this is exactly what i well
that's why i come to this workshop
trying to
you know ask you guys to think about
this and learn something
okay so now let's go back to elementary
complexity theory
okay we have the simple function that
takes three inputs
each one of them takes one of those
copper colors
and the function is simply saying i want
all of them to be distinct okay so this
is edge coloring back i'm add a degree
three vertex i want sweet
triple of colors coming in and i will
say it's no good if at least two colors
are the same otherwise it's gonna be
okay if they're all distinct okay
and then you can put this into the
holland framework where you just apply
the all distinct function at every
vertex then the fourier three regular
graph this holland value is the number
of valid three edge coloring is that
clear you know this is just another way
of saying things okay the sum is going
to be one
if and only if at every vertex
the all distinct constraint is satisfied
otherwise it's killed by the zero
but of course you don't have to think
about just
this sort of function you can think of a
more general function
that if x y z comes in k different
colors uh if they're all distinct to
some value if they're all the same
there's some value if two of them are
the same and one of them is different
they have some other value right you can
think of these so dichotomy theorems are
basically trying to
classify according to every function you
can put here what kind of
complexity of computing this sum of
product computation is all about
okay so um
so in this particular case that we are
going to prove in which this edge
coloring is approved is the following
function where if they're all the same i
give you value a if
two are the same one is different that
give you value b and if they're all
distinct that give you c
so it's described by
three complex numbers
now you may wonder why do i even go to
complex well it turns out that
just like this transformation over here
even if the original problem was all
non-negative or 0 1 even the freedom
that pro that permitted by you to use
these complex transformations using
various eigenvalues and so on becomes
very useful so it would be useful to not
restrict a priori to
just
uh zero one abcs
and of course the all distinct one is in
this notation is just a zero zero one
okay so if you know the only value is
non-zero is one when they're all
distinct otherwise
is that clear so far i mean everything
is very elementary at this point right
okay now let me just
mention a little bit of the other
frameworks i've been talking about
holland problems really uh there is uh
basically probably the best studied
framework in these three frameworks is
graph homomorphism
uh it came from originally at least came
from as early as 1967
uh
lassi lobos actually has an i think an
abiding interest in in this topic where
if you look onto his website on this
particular page there's listed something
for 40 you know so papers over 40 years
where he himself was at least the
co-author of so there's a lot of
interesting and beautiful stuff was done
and the way is is defined as follows
you're given an n by n symmetric or k by
k symmetric matrix
and the input is a graph
and then the output is the sum of
product thing again and now what is this
sum of product is a sum where you assign
every vertex of the input graph g to one
of those kappa colors or
one of those columns or rows
and then for every particular assignment
you multiply for every edge of the input
graph g of the target value where a is
let me let me illustrate this by an
example
so for example
if you have the matrix of 0 1 1 1
okay
and there are two colors zero one
namely and for every graph this this is
some sort of matrix h
and then for every graph
you are assigning now uh
vertices of the graph
to a zero or one
okay you're picking the vertex or not to
pick the vertex per each vertex you're
picking a subset of vertices
okay
subject to the constraint that for every
two vertices
that is picked 0 0 that is no good
so you don't allow
a picking of a set of vertices so that
there are two vertices if you think of
zero as an unpicked one as picked
so it's a little quiz what's this
problem
number of uh i guess that's your
terminology for
for for vertex cover this is vertex
cover you want to pick a set of vertices
so that there are no edges hanging out
there that are totally untouched
so this is a counting number vertex cup
and if you take this matrix then it's
the number of vertex coloring
okay so this is saying that i allow you
to assign any one of the copper colors
for every vertex provided for every edge
it is not assigned the same on both
sides
okay
all right
so now for this we have a dichotomy this
is joint work with xi chen and pinyan lu
this we worked really really hard for so
the dichotomy theorem says that you give
an arbitrary symmetric complex valued
matrix
this problem which was this partition
function called the z
okay computing this thing which by
definition of course takes exponentially
many the definitional way of computing
it takes exponentially many terms but it
might be that you can do it in a
different way so that's the whole point
of complexity theory right you might do
it efficiently and
the the theorem says that
uh this computation for an input g is
either in polynomial time or sharply
hard for the class of value
so what's the dimension of the
underlying vector space that you're
uh
operating on vector space what vector
space
you mean the the type the a all the
possible a so
this the the tractable ones the ones
that have polynomial time computability
do not form a linear subspace
no i yeah yeah so no i'm just so in
if you fix i guess the number of the the
size of the graph for the season edges
you don't fix the graph you fix the a
that sort of talks about what problem
you're talking about like vertex cover
so this two by two matrix is the a
that tells you i'm talking about vertex
cover problem now the input is g
which has n vertices and m edges but
yeah absolutely so
so it has
right so if you have n vertices and
edges or whatever right then
uh
so you you compute i mean the function
is finite terry computable the question
is does it take two to the n steps
or something like that
so the naive is is this two to the end
well it's copper to the end or something
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
suppose a particular matrix is hard to
compute so there's some graph
right
well there's a sequence i mean this is
always a complexity it's not a single
graph so it's an infinite family of a g
for which it is well it could be easy
for some inputs oh yeah yeah of course i
mean if i give you the empty graph
there's no uh
nothing to so is it
that's not a very well defined question
right i mean so what does it mean by for
a given graph
for a given family of graphs probably
you're probably meant for a given family
of graphs for example if the graph is a
planar is it possible
and this actually goes back to the match
gates question where
there's a running thesis where we would
say that
the the type of these computations of
the partition function coming three
varieties those which are in polynomial
time
and the rest are in sharpie hard
precisely and then for those which comes
in two precise separations those which
are over planar as hard easy and
those which are still hard and the
middle one is precisely those which are
under holographic transformation to be
solvable by mexicans
so this is something we have theorems
about say boolean domain theorems and
symmetric signatures but not as fully
general as this theorem this is
this theorem i should say that uh well
we worked very hard but there are fan
fantastic work before by
martin dyer and and green hill katherine
green hill
for the zero one case bulatov
grow for the non-negative case
and then jrm goldberg
grow and 30 for the
real
positive or negative case
and for the for the full generalities
here
so when you say planar graphs you mean
minor close families or just really just
planar actually planar so you can draw
it on something yes do you also have the
description for which a it's like that
yes that's a very good question and this
actually
so this this this particular thing says
so let me just phrase his question
properly so everyone understand what the
question is first of all there are
there's the question of uh given an a
fixed
the computational problem of a given g
what's the complexity of computing the
partition function of z sub a of g
okay so a is fixed a is constant
but then you can say since there is a
dichotomy for every a it's either this
type of that part that kind of
computation that from g to c of g then
you can say given a
which way is it
okay and this actually
is doable also in polynomial time and
this is another
uh some work it uses some
non-trivial uh
algebraic number theory by a thesis
of ger who's a student of landscape
so there's this is not obvious but it
can be done but but then let me
accentuate this by saying that we have
actually a
on the face of it a stronger fear
okay this theorem says that you give me
an arbitrary constraint satisfaction
problem so this can be viewed as the
special case where you have a single
binary symmetric function
and even in that case it was hard but
this theorem uses a lot of work up there
so it's it's not in
it builds on that okay
and there we don't have the the decision
procedure so if you give me 17 functions
if you give me two functions
uh i don't know how to
tell which way it went
but the theorem still says that
the two functions of 25 billion
functions is a constant defines a csp
problem which is
the input is this you know variables and
constraints apply like a graph and then
you ask the partition function which is
summing over all possible assignments of
the variables and multiply over the
constraints okay and that partition
function computation is either in p or
sharp depending on what this
set of 25 billion constant many
functions are
but to tell which way it went we don't
know at this point
it is decidable if the constraint
functions are non-negative it is
actually a theorem of martin dyer and
richard b
to show that if it's zero one is
decidable
uh uh it's another theorem um with me
and my co-authors for non-negative but i
want to emphasize there's a big
difference between
these kind of functions where the
constraint functions are non-negative
versus possibly positive and negative
and complex because the cancellation is
where the
very sneaky and efficient algorithms
happen like the determinant of versus
permanent if you will okay if there are
no cancellations then it's relatively
easy to s i shouldn't say that
um
anyway let me just stop here with
cancellation it's harder because there
are very
unintuitive ways of doing it so i'll
show you some examples right away
so the main theorem is that the edge
coloring
is as a special case of this dichotomy
where the zero zero one is the case and
this for every abc is a sharpie
or in polynomial okay so that's the
dichotomy we want to say
until
15 minutes
okay better go fast um
okay so edge coloring is zero zero one
tens okay all right now let me show you
some
tractable problems okay they're actually
in polynomial time solvable and they're
not obvious so the function is say for
example they're all coming in the same
five if two of them are saying one
different two if they're all different
negative four
boom that problem is solvable in
polynomial remember what the problem is
the graph comes in
uh you assign all exponentially many
assignments and then you evaluate this
product and you sum up all these
exponentially many terms okay this is
polynomial time computable
and that the way why it is computable is
by this holographic transformation but
now over the three by three domain and
you express as these tensor sums and
this should really appeal to the heart
of the audience here and you express
this in this orthogonal transformation
of the original vectors and this gives
you a way to say that i can somehow
solve it okay so this is
it's not a totally obvious thing i'm
skipping a lot of details confuse that
this seems a symmetric cancer yes it is
it is exactly these are symmetric ones
uh in general you can say you know for
copper colors and copper square minus
six copper plus four
okay you've got a point all right so
some things that are
not obvious but remember if you want to
prove dichotomy theorems you better not
prove this thing hard
okay they got this in polynomial time
this is like
subterranean polynomial time solvable
things and you look over the sea and you
really want to carve out everything and
you better not hit one of those rocks
right
i mean you're not going to prove a
polynomial time computable thing shocky
hard
well maybe that's better if you did that
but let's not go into that right do you
understand so
to be you know sanity check you should
try to prove just those which are not in
polynomial time shall be hard and those
which are actually important at the time
leave them alone don't try to prove them
sharply hard you shouldn't
overreach no essence
or maybe you want to overreach but
anyway
good
so for combat domain four for example
here something okay again minus three
plus four
things that are not totally obvious and
i'm a little confused so when you show
something is in p yeah are you also
producing the algorithm
in this case it does
in the case of the csp dichotomy that i
mentioned that i don't have a decision
procedure for
it's a little more subtle
i produce and this is with a sheet we
produce a polynomial time algorithm so
the algorithm is actually there it's not
a purely existential proof
the algorithm is there however to prove
that the algorithm always worked
demands that a certain property
of a certain infinitary object
is satisfied
and this infinitary object comes from
these 75 billion constraint functions
75 billion constant but it generates an
infinitary thing and then you either say
you have the property or you don't and
they have the property this algorithm
will always work if you don't have the
property then i will show otherwise it
shall be hard so that's how the proof
went there but here it's much more
constructive we actually give the actual
polynomial time algorithm for every one
of those problems that we show is in
polynomial time and for everything else
in this particular framework of these
constraint functions of abc we show that
it is sharpie we prove a reduction
okay
so
let me now move a little bit into the
ideas of proof uh it uses the top
polynomial so this is the top polynomial
and if you haven't seen this before
then not much point for me to explain
it's number of connected components and
so on okay
and it encodes a lot of information
about the uh the graph
a special case of this uh
specializing to this is the chroma
chromatic polymer that's the number of
vertex colors colorings
vertigen has a theorem that says that
the top polynomial
is either in polynomial time or sharpie
hard
and it is described precisely at these
points
that are important over time
and otherwise it shall be
okay there's a known theorem
now let me introduce you what is called
a medial graph so here's a graph
and you take every edge so there's a
planar graph and you take every edge and
you sort of connect an edge if that
the edges are incident are next to each
other
to a particular region to a particular
face okay so it's clear what what i'm
doing so for example this i will connect
to here connector here connector here
connect back
okay so that's called a medial graph and
by definition a medial graph is always a
for regular
in fact you can define what's called a
directed medial graph where uh the
cycles are always such that the vertices
the original vertices are inside and the
original faces are the outside
so so counterclockwise this way
clockwise that way
now a graph is eulerian if every vertex
has an even degree
and the directed graph is oil airing if
the ink degree is always equal to the
out degree it's like you can go in and
come out and come in and come out you
never really have to be stuck there
right that's good but it's not required
in this definition
eulerian to be connected usually it is
assumed to be connected
all right so
given the graph
a connected planar graph there is a way
to connect
the top polynomial evaluated at the
diagonal points
to a certain sum over
the
labelings which are called eulerian
labeling
okay
and with with various factors and this
is two to the number of monochromatic
vertices so let's think a little bit
about what media graph locally direct
media graph locally the configuration
must look like it must look like this
because this was the original edge
basically okay
so you come and go out coming all the
way
cyclically must be in out in out
so to be eulerian of coloring it either
is all the same color that's fine right
okay two in two out
or one in one out of two different
colors
and this is one possibility
and there's another possibility and
that's the only possibility
okay and in that sum
it is only the monochromatic vertices
that will give you a factor two locally
and two to the number of such
monochromic factors is the total sum
otherwise you just think this fact is
one
and in this way you can think of
the
sum the sum over the eulerian on the
directed
medial graph as a holland problem where
the signature says it's a 2 1 0 1 0.
what is 2 2 says all four things are the
same that gives you two
and this says that these two are the
same these two are the same this says
that these two are the same these two
are the same and this is like these two
are the same these two are the same and
that's not good that's not allowed
because the in out in out
okay so if you think about this it takes
a little thinking but
basically this sum is the holland
problem so
the
top dichotomy gives me hardness over the
medial graph on this particular
signature what we call signature or
constraint function 2 1 0 1 0.
okay and now if you assign the all
distinct signature in this particular
graph you can compute that it comes out
to be something like this
okay that this is a simple way to
compute i'll just not go through it it's
again if they're all the same has to be
zero because this is distinct so this w
cannot equal to z and so on so forth
now if you take the gadget which is just
two parallel lines then you can compute
another one again it's just a simple
computation
and now uh we are ready sort of to talk
about the outline of this proof of the
edge coloring
we'll reduce this problem to that
remember this is the sum over these
medial graph eulerian partitions which
ultimately go to the top polynomial that
is known to be sharpie hard
and we're going to reduce this to
this is the edge coloring that for three
regular graphs all distinct is three
edge coloring and we're going to assign
this thing on each one of those vertices
and construct the sequence of gadgets
and
again a moment of reflection would
suggest that the
constraint functions on these four
inputs can be written
on as as a five-dimensional vector as an
iteration of a matrix to its power over
an initial f0 which is this two parallel
lines
so this this again takes a little uh
thinking but uh it's not it's elementary
so there's a i mean at least sort of
philosophically you should agree with me
that if i do this iteration there should
be a matrix iterating of things right so
that shouldn't be a surprise
but for this particular matrix uh it
turns out that's the case and then what
we would like to do is to decompose it
into spectral decomposition into its
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
okay and once i do that then i have a
very nice way of writing this into
uh some entries where the x are the
uh the color minus one number to this
number of iterations of 2s where this
signature is being iterated
okay so now this is the idea of called
interpolation
i would like to
somehow reduce this problem which was
remember this is a
version of the touch polynomial
computation i want to reduce the
computation of this to the edge coloring
problem
okay so we
assume that i have an edge coloring as a
way to
as an oracle access if you will about
this all distinct function
and assume this problem which is the
thought part problem
where this signature appears n times
and you would replace each one of those
end times by the sequence of two s s is
another independent parameter of this
gadget which is made up of this
edge coloring signature all distinct
and once you do that then the polynomial
as the final value can be viewed as a
polynomial of this x where the
coefficients do not depend on
this number s of iterations
is encapsulated into this s
and then what you do is you you evaluate
this at some n plus one points
sufficiently large polynomial many and
then you interpolate the polynomial once
you reinterpolate the polynomial you
plug in the desired x which gives you
back the original
touch quality so this is a little fast
and
if you didn't get all the details that's
okay all i'm saying is that i have a way
to transform the top polynomial
evaluation into the edge coloring
problem
whereby i use some spectral techniques
to express things as polynomials and
then when i evaluate at this potentially
uh
available problem which is called edge
coloring at some n plus one instances i
can reconstruct a certain polynomial
which then i can reconstruct the
original dot so therefore the
computation of the top is polynomially
reducible to the edge coloring if i
could access the edge coloring and
therefore it must be hard because
originally i couldn't do it right
okay so that's the logic
um
now the
few minutes of uh
words on the
um an outline of the full dichotomy it's
really
probably too much for me to finish um
so let me skip this and give you a
flavor of the structure of this proof
what i have done is is told you a little
bit thing here and every little circle
is sort of a serum and lemon what i have
used some logical dependency
and um yeah it's a it's a 70-some page
thing so a lot of work went in
but uh but let me highlight something
that has to do with the zego theorem
because this is how i start this talk
with okay so let me now define what is
called a lattice condition
so give me some
number of nonzero complex numbers
i ask what kind of
exponents integer exponents of x i such
that the product can equal to 1.
more precisely i want to say it
satisfies the lattice condition if for
any non-zero tuple of integer exponents
x
subject to the sum that being 0
that this product is never equal to 1.
if you take the logarithm of this this
is a linear dependency over the
rationals that's what really is i don't
want to talk about the log because for
the complex then you have to talk about
what branch you take and so i want to by
bypass that complexity okay so this is
the formal definition but essentially it
is about rational dependency of these
presumably transcendental numbers
good and now there's a theorem which i
don't want to read the full thing for
you but i just want you to focus on here
that when you have these iterative
matrices where the powers of which that
i described to you in the five by five
case in particular if the eigenvalue
satisfies certain lattice conditions
that the one that i described then i
have a reduction okay so the theorem
basically says i want these
eigenvalues to be sufficiently
independent in the sense of the
logarithm of which is rationally
independent
and
the actual reduction that will come out
is something like this
okay so it's a nine by nine uh
recurrence matrix of which i can scribe
take out some four dimensions which are
trivial uh
eigenvalues being orthogonal so it
distills down into a
five degree five polynomial where kappa
is the number of colors
and if you normalize it you get a
quintic polynomial in x
with integer parameter kappa
and if you think about this kappa as
another integer parameter you have a
particular
polynomial with integer coefficients in
two variables x and y
and what we really would like to say is
that for every y integer parameter the
kappa parameter this as a quantity
polynomial in x
have eigenvalues of five eigenvalues
satisfy the lattice condition
this is what we really want to do
and um
so
presumably for every integer y big and
equal to four this is
irreducible and we can't prove that and
we can prove for every fixed y but we
can prove for every integer y big and
equal to 4 is irreducible
if it is irreducible we can prove again
using galwa theory that it satisfies the
lattice condition
we do know that this polynomial have
these five integer solutions
and of course for these particular
integer places you don't have
irreducibility but we would like to say
is that for y big and equal to four as
an integer it is irreducible
okay so now the the proof sort of
bifurcates into two parts one deals with
when it's irreducible one deals with
maybe it is not irreducible we believe
it won't be not irreducible but we can't
prove it
but nevertheless we're going to try to
arrive at a conclusion
oh okay so let me just finish in two
minutes then so
um
what we'd like to say is that
even if it's not irreducible which i
don't believe it's the case it doesn't
have linear factors
when it doesn't have linear factors it
factors into a quadratic and a cubic and
in that in that case we further
discussed this galwa group and trying to
show that satisfy the lattice condition
so the real crust is to say that there
are no integer solutions beyond the
trivial ones
and um
maybe i'll just
okay let me just show one more slide it
says that the final
way to show that
uh there are no integer solutions is to
appeal this device called the pursue
series
so you expand this with these fractional
around expansions near the roots
and then argue that
a certain functions
that should be integer if
x and y are integer solutions would have
been an integer
however we argue that it must go down
to zero but not entirely zero so it's
going down like this with an effective
constant both bounded above and below so
it would be something a fractional
number when x is large so it'll be
between zero and one therefore it's not
integer
and that contradicts the assumption that
x and y are integer solutions to it and
this
uh
this um this technique is sometimes
called a longest method
thank you very much
so thanks for the very interesting
can you questions just one example let's
say of your theory about this matrix
let's say what's just something that i
can just understand you know for example
let's say if a computing permanent you
know
the permanent is not technically because
um it's not a locally constrained
problem but there are things that are
very similar to that for example
if you take the again let's say take the
ottama matrix
so
let's say you take the matrix which is 1
1 1 -1
and that's your you know graph
homomorphism problem
and then you're assigning zeros on the
ones on the on every vertex and look at
every edge and the every edge if it's
you know zero zero zero one
zero zero zero one one zero one one
right there are four possibilities and
only here it will contribute to negative
one
so in other words when you take a set of
vertices as thinking of taking the one
vertices as picked
then all the edges are ignored except
the edges are between two ones
so that's an induced sub graph
and then you're asking
is an all the even number of induced
subgraphs
because it's minus one to the power of
the edges so this question of the
partition function in this particular
case
is the number of even induced subgraphs
minus the number of all the induced
subgraphs
of course the sum is obvious it's two to
the n to the number of induced subgroups
so therefore
if you know the difference then you know
the sum you already know the sum so you
know each part so this is essentially
the problem of computing the number of
all the induced subgraphs or the number
of even induced subgraphs it's like a
permanent determinant in this case but
except the sum in this case like
permanent is actually computable so the
determinant is also computed in this
sense so you actually get both the even
part and the output so this is one of
those computable problems
that's right that's a polynomial time
computable problem
and it's very easy to construct things
that are not computable if you put
something like
another root of unity over here it will
be not good
so i guess
after you're here i should believe that
there is no way to express math
isomorphism
in this class
uh
well
this is actually a theorem that uh
um
these these these sort of globally
constrained things cannot be expressed
in this
magnetic logic and thing but i think
what you're saying is that you think
graph isomorphism is neither in p nor
np-complete
i was just asking how do i see directly
that it can't be expressions yeah it
probably you know that's one way to
think about it i guess that since it's
not expressible here the dichotomy
theorem doesn't apply but i'm not so
sure i actually agree with you that the
graph isomorphism is not in p so that's
you know
thanks
other
question
so if not we thank you
okay